[Musique]
quand par les enfants au soir
patron je suis très anciens êtes vous
bien sûr que nous sommes au-dessus de la
maison de nicolas et d'autres pas
preneur mais oui nounours nous y sommes
je vous crois bon
pop up en patron oui vous n'auriez pas
lampe de poche
tiens et nord ce qui ne va pas me dire
que tu as peur non mais il fait très
sombre ce soir d'un fonds
propre épopée comme
[Musique]
mais il fait tout noir là dedans y'a
personne
nicolas
un preneur
en tard qu'elle retient il est très tôt
les cornichons il nous a dit de dormir
tôt car demain en salles est basse et
lundi matin 1 600 wii pourra léguer à
mes champignons ya pas de champignons
ici nous emmener très loin
au avec data vous lui ferez toutes mes
amitiés
je vous laisse dormir et cornichons il
est dans la cuisine
je vais lui dire bonsoir
[Musique]
mais il n'est pas dans la cuisine
cornichons où es tu oui je suis là
comment tu es dehors ouais je dors à la
baille un label à la belle étoile nours
il dort à la belle victoire sur le
balcon au bon pourquoi pas à la belle de
nuit comme les shows salut ça allait
dans les champs salut de noces
[Musique]
je viens voilà tu cherche quelque chose
vient de coucher nicolas
[Musique]
les enfants vous ne savez pas cornichons
cache la toupine avec son petit déjeuner
les vilains coups ne fait pas tant de
bruit tu la trouveras pas lorsqu'un
maison la tâche et elle est tellement
bien caché quatre personnes la trouvera
c'est comme ces souliers puiqu'il les
arranger on leur trouve plus belle vache
tiennent une aile veinards est bien de
même temps vous les trouverez il ne faut
pas qu'ils sortent eux viennent il
pourrait se faire mal et puisque vous
vous lever tôt en dormez-vous vite
bonheur ça lui fait de boer
non
[Musique]
ennui les enfants en patron que c'est
agréable d'être un label à la belle ola
plus toile voulons c'est vrai le ciel et
pau ce soir et des étoiles brillent
allons en route bonne nuit des enfants
faites de beaux rêves
salut
[Musique]